black history and other things Banning
books has been weaponized for political
purposes check out this clip on The View
yesterday was it last week last week I
said you know my mom always says to me
she always says David you know when
you're talking about the view that you
always call Sarah Haynes you never say
her name you always say her she's the
she's the blonde lady uh so I tried to
give her a little credit I said her name
but listen to this abject nonsense from
the blonde lady I mean Sarah Haynes or
whatever I think there's there's more to
it than that look I think what it is is
that um black history and other things
Banning books has been weaponized for
political purposes to drive people to
the polls based on outrage because my
poor little white kid is feeling bad
because he's learning about slavery
that's ridiculous learning about history
should not make anybody feel bad we
learn about history should make you feel
bad but it's important that it makes you
feel bad I don't think it should make
make you feel bad I mean I don't think a
white child uh that's had nothing to do
with slavery should feel bad about
slavery I think we need to learn history
so that we don't repeat the same as
about history and Naro is just
disgusting right because if your child
is being taught that they are bad
because they are white uh yeah you
should have sympathy for them and you
should get them out of that school but
then Sarah Haynes right there at the end
history should make you feel bad no it
shouldn't No it should not it doesn't
mean that history is perfectly clean it
doesn't mean that the founding of this
country is perfectly clean it doesn't
mean that slavery and everything is
perfectly clean but you can give an
honest assessment without making kids
feel bad about who they are these but
again I'm trying to show you how all of
the bad ideas of the left have have just
leaked into every institution cultural
institutions our TV networks our news
we're not going to we're not going to
show you Donald Trump he says mean
things we'll decide what you need to
know